hey everybody what's going on here is my
review of cobra kai season four i've
been a big fan of cobra kai since when
it was on youtube to now netflix i was a
big fan of the karate kid films one to
three after that
but one to three i liked a lot and so i
loved how this show has taken this
direction from a different perspective
the writing has been brilliant and that
does continue in season four now to me
season four in a nutshell is a
transitional season i think we've seen a
lot of these story lines play out over
and over through season one to three
in season four you do feel it does get a
little bit tiring in some ways
but the way they set up season five
because they're already talking about
it's already online but they haven't
given anything away
they're going to take the show into a
different direction which i'm glad
they're doing and i'm excited for that
and especially how they teased it
because we're going to see some new
characters and some characters we saw in
the past
come back into the fold for season five
i'm not gonna spoil this uh season for
you in this review okay i'll touch on
some things but i'm not gonna spoil the
overall story lines okay all right so
let's talk about some of the highlights
in season four season four is really
about finding your own path it's not
just about the defensive way of miyagi's
karate or what daniel thinks miyagi's
karate is or the offensive way of the
cobra kai style or karate that you know
johnny lawrence knows it's really about
finding your own path and the
combination of both okay now of course
we do see season three ending off johnny
and daniel joining up dojos to battle
cobra kai in the all valley tournament
we're back at the old valley tournament
again but um
as you can probably imagine you even saw
in the trailers that
there are some differences here right
there are some differences in the way
that they teach and their method of
teaching which makes for some really
funny moments throughout the season some
laugh out loud moments that i think are
great and you find out that these guys
are not that much different i mean of
course we've sort of seen that through
seasons one to three but you really find
it here in season four that there is a
common ground that these guys have if
they just would stop being so stubborn
and do they stop or do they continue it
that's what part of season four is all
about
now there of course is the introduction
to terry silver which i was so pumped
about when they were teasing this at the
end of season three and of course in the
trailers thomas ian griffith is back he
is in top form he brings terry silver to
life i mean he's diabolical he's a
maniac
he's many different things and the
writers because you have a season to
work on terry silver can really flesh
out this character a lot more and what's
funny about this show is really when you
think about it i mean
you got these older guys like someone
like daniel russo who's very successful
you know they are their whole life
revolves around these dojos and this all
valley tournament and then here you get
terry silver who's a multi-millionaire
successful businessman and why does he
come back into this world so you have to
sort of suspend reality for a moment to
uh take in this show but when you do it
is very fun to watch and how crease
brings terry silver back into it of
course is that emotional manipulation
you know as we know from the previous
story lines kris saved terry silver's
life in vietnam so there's always this
debt that silver has towards kris
and he even if he doesn't necessarily
agree with kris on some ways
he sometimes has to take that
you know he has to take a step back
because
this is the man that saved his life
but does he take that step back
or is there something bigger planned
with terry silva
that
is something about season four which is
really interesting not gonna give
anything else away okay let's talk about
some of the standout younger characters
in season four i think tori uh was a
great character i think we've seen her
as kind of the bad girl and she's got
this you know this animosity towards
samantha and you know jealousy and all
that but we kind of find out why she is
the way she is and you could see her
struggles in life and that she just
you know she comes from a broken home
and you really learn about this a lot
more you actually she's getting help
from a character that you might not
think would help her out
and it is kind of shocking and it's kind
of adds a nice element to her storyline
in a lot of ways you could see her
struggle
from being this bad girl to trying to be
someone respected and admired and i like
that journey with her character and
we saw this with robbie as well i mean
robbie's character's got a great
development and this is in the storyline
especially because he's now with cobra
kai and now with the introduction of
terry silver and with robbie
how does this work how does it work now
with crease silver
and robbie does robbie get manipulated
the same way that daniel did in karate
kid uh three from terry silver or
did something else happen
so i like what they did with that now
speaking of robbie i also got to talk
about that uh love triangle robbie
torrey miguel and samantha okay to be
frank with you this love triangle is
getting really boring because mcgill and
samantha just don't have chemistry man
they just don't i'm sorry um no
disrespect to the actors i don't know if
it's a directing or if it's the writing
or if it's just the actors maybe
some people have chemistry some don't
but
it's kind of like watching brother and
sister dating it's a little odd it
really is you know and as much as they
try to
build up this romance in season four
it's uh
it's just not there guys you know i mean
for the moments that robbie and samantha
see each other man the sparks fly the
eyes i mean pam you're like okay these
guys really want to hook up even though
they're trying not to you can see there
is that passion there but with miguel
it's like eh okay whatever but miguel's
storyline is actually very interesting
in this season because
you know obviously he has this dynamic
with johnny then with the introduction
with the dojos how does he take to uh
daniel does he get along with daniel
does he not you know especially that
he's dating you know daniel's daughter
how does this all come to play so these
are there's some really nice moments in
season four with this that i think are
really interesting and it kind of you
know the perceptions that people have of
daniel russo because he doesn't really
share about his backstory that much to a
lot of people they realize hey wait a
second
you know there's some common ground in a
lot of ways
and there's also they touch on some
really interesting social angles as well
cyber bullying there's a new character
that comes into play don't want to give
away too much but uh you really feel for
this this character you really do and
one of the bullies out there is someone
you wouldn't
expect that's all i'm gonna say
but it does this character has a really
nice uh story arc through season four
which of course i think will carry on
into season five as well now another
part of the season does touch on the
social justice issues you know like
gender identity sexual preferences all
that stuff
and they do it in a way that is not
quote-unquote woke uh or anything else
like that but they do it in a sense
where you get to see it from
johnny's perspective in some ways and
it's funny the way they do it because
there's no opinion
it's just showing that how an older
generation sees these things versus the
younger generation and vice versa so if
you're
you know someone that's younger watching
the show you might watch this going oh i
never thought they would look at it that
way and vice versa so i
like how they did it and they used
johnny lawrence as the vessel which is
hilarious because there's some laugh out
loud moments which you were like oh this
is great this is fantastic how they did
it but um they don't believe you're it
too much but they just touch on it
because of course these are topics of
the day but uh how they intertwine it
with this 1980s johnny lawrence is just
funny it really really is um but you
know i have to say this i mean there
will be some complaints about season
four because obviously this was shot
during the pandemic and you are going to
see some of those limitations come into
the production aspect of it so you sort
of have to take this important parcel
that they probably couldn't tell the
story that they maybe wanted to tell in
season four for the most part because of
these restrictions and the limitations
but i think now that uh you know
productions are you know ramping back up
things are ongoing i think season five
is going to come out with a really big
bang and i'm really looking forward to
it but i do hope that they sort of you
know change directions a little bit now
and you know make the show
its own going into season five yes still
bringing the characters but i think this
rehashing of the dojos and the all
valley tournaments after a while
i know it's part and parcel and it is
part of the lore of the karate kid
franchise but it's not everything and i
hope that they move on past that but
anyway those are my thoughts on cobra
kai season 4 let me know your thoughts
in the comment section below uh have you
seen it what do you think are you
excited to watch it i would love to hear
from you guys with that follow us on
facebook subscribe to us on youtube like
this video helps out our channel a lot
and i will chat you soon take care
[Music]